[Music]
this morning gulf coast residents
continued to deal with the aftermath of
hurricane laura which caused damage far
inland as well it arrived just before
the anniversary of a more destructive
storm
15 years ago this weekend hurricane
katrina
made landfall devastating new orleans
and the surrounding region
soon after one non-profit group got to
work
first in new orleans and now far and
wide helping homeowners pick up the
pieces
and rebuild their future
we just started a three-year 10 million
dollar campaign to rebuild 240 houses
hello young people
when we first met zach rosenberg and his
wife liz mccartney in 2015
their non-profit the saint bernard
project had rebuilt
614 homes in the new orleans area
it was kind of like the field of dreams
you build it and it would come
volunteers started coming out of the
wooden work one two
three today
sbp as it's now known has helped rebuild
more than 2500 homes
and the mission has expanded we just
built the first
net zero apartment building in all of
louisiana that means
solar panels powering batteries and 50
of those units are for veterans
rosenberg
says everything changed after meeting
world war
ii vet edward lee five years ago
we met the 94 year old who built his own
home
with his own hands home means
a hundred percent of my life katrina's
winds blew part of his roof off and
cracked his foundation
he patched up what he could with fema
money but ran
out before the job was done you never
thought of moving out of this house
no i'm gonna die
but not before volunteers made his house
whole again
he lived another three years and died
his family says
a happy man getting to know mr lee
changed the way we saw
our work it wasn't about building houses
and we're still doing more than ever
before
but it was about preventing the need to
rebuild the houses in the first place
since our last report sbp has gone
national
the nonprofit has helped homeowners from
missouri to the mid-atlantic
to the caribbean they've done it by
streamlining the
operation cutting in half the time it
takes to build a house
this houston home was refurbished with
roofing able to withstand
135 mile per hour winds and that
preparedness extends to cutting through
red tape the first way to do it is help
people understand and mitigate their
risk
we just got to 19 million people by july
to educate them on flood insurance and
as important we train people after
disaster to navigate the system
to avoid contractor fraud to navigate
fema
to work with insurance so it sounds to
me like you front load
resources to them before they even need
them absolutely
the mission has become a calling for
rosenberg and mccartney
who picked up and moved to new orleans
15 years ago
how's everybody a spirit of sacrifice
needed now
more than ever here we are two
hurricanes in the gulf
you have fires in the west you have
tornadoes and other storms throughout
the midwest
how do you ratchet up when it's coming
at you from so many different sides
so we have deployment calls we are ready
to respond to
any disaster that hits within 36 hours
this year even with covid local
volunteers
who if and when something happens can
immediately
be there in their own community because
i'll tell you this michelle one of our
country's biggest assets
is the concern that fellow people have
for fellow citizens people from across
the country
who have gone to disaster to help other
people and they're ready to do it again
and i think frankly that will be very
healing at this time
and sbp has helped people in the region
impacted by hurricane laura and they say
they already have their teams in place
assessing the damage as we speak so
they're really gearing up
for today because today is when they're
actually getting on the ground
it's so many steps ahead then we then so
many were
back with katrina because of them and
this is just one non-profit there are
many others
so they can pop up so quickly now i mean
and just take action and and it's not
just
built rebuilding the home to prevent it
from being damaged in the next one it is
those relationships right
between the workers yes it's really a
joy to see
mr lee stayed in touch with all the
folks who worked in his home it was
quite level yeah great yeah